نعلم جميعًا أن الإجهاد يمكن أن يستنزف جسمك
الآن ، أظهرت دراسة جديدة أنه قد يؤدي أيضًا إلى تقلص
عقلك ، وقد نُشر في مجلة
علم الأعصاب وجد باحثو علم الأعصاب صلة
بين المستويات العالية من هرمون الإجهاد
الكورتيزول وحجم الدماغ
ووظيفة الكورتيزول هو هرمون يتم إطلاقه
عندما نكون كذلك  يقول الباحثون المتوترون وفي حالة تأهب قصوى
إنه إذا كنت
متوتراً باستمرار ، فقد
يتعطل جسمك مما يؤدي إلى الإصابة بأمراض القلب
، وزيادة الوزن وصعوبة
النوم ، لكن هذا البحث الأخير وجد أن
مستويات الكورتيزول المرتفعة تؤثر أيضًا على
عقلك ، ويقول الباحثون إن الإجهاد يمكن أن
يؤدي أيضًا إلى  قضايا فقدان الذاكرة
والتركيز ، نظرت الدراسة في
أكثر من 2000 شخص خضعوا لاختبارات
لقياس مهاراتهم في التفكير بعد حوالي
ثماني سنوات من الاختبار الأول
وجد الباحثون أن الأشخاص الذين لديهم
أعلى مستويات من الكورتيزول لديهم أكبر قدر من
فقدان الذاكرة اكتشف الباحثون أيضًا أن
الكورتيزول يؤثر على بنية الدماغ.
والحجم يقول إن المستويات المرتفعة من
الهرمون مرتبطة بتلف بعض أجزاء
تشير الدراسة أيضًا إلى أن الأشخاص الذين
لديهم مستويات عالية من الكورتيزول لديهم
أدمغة أصغر في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم ، أنا
آندي روز